hey youtubers is Charlie I hope you guys
won money on bets abouts avatar we got
to talk all about this reveal what it
means and how they change the comics
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen it yet the really cool thing about
the reveal too is it almost raises more
questions than it answers which is the
mark of a good twit
so congratulations if you guessed it
right if not it's not that big a deal
there was a lot of evidence for
different characters but towards the end
more and more as we got closer and
closer to this actual reveal just the
way they were marketing things the
foreshadowing in the metaphors and
characters dialogue the plot lines just
started to point towards Barry being the
villain of the season
the way the reverse-flash talked about
it at the very beginning so you see how
it circles back around and now somewhere
in the speedforce where he's kind of
dead kind of not dead the reverse-flash
is chuckling to himself haha I'm right
flash you're the villain but there's a
new brand of the blast ring giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
so let's do top 10 WTF comic book Easter
eggs obviously he's the future flash
based on the set up here what they're
doing is they're crossing this seminal
mark waid blast story terminal velocity
which was a wally west story with the
future flash story from the new 52
comics so I will explain those two
different comic book stories as we go
along but thematically they're very true
to that original future version of Barry
from 20 plus years in the future so
that's how much older the comic book
version of Barry is but number 10 meet
Tracy brand speedforce PhD candidate so
I love the meet-cute that they have they
go in and she's burning all her research
I'm trash I'm garbage I failed my PhD
dissertation so it's just a way to show
you how like this future person who
designs this amazing track that allows
them to keeps avatar in the Speed Force
is nowhere close to being that person
she's getting ready to hop a bus to go
for a job interview at big belly burger
in there's some awkward comedy with hrs
character they're sort of teasing a
future relationship with those
characters so he says like funny sayings
from earth 19 turning tubers into finger
chips Norbert Einstein just a funny way
to introduce the character and you can
see the energy that she brings is a lot
of what's missing now that Caitlyn is
full-blown killer frost although there
is hope that they'll bring her back but
it just sounds like unless there's a big
twist in the finale the Tracy's place on
the team is going to be more permanent
in the future and even though they're
coming
a little hard and bass with that HR
relationship stuff I feel like she'll be
a good bit but she's not a character
from the comics she's an original
creation of the show in number nine she
explains her research she's been
studying extra dimensional energy she's
basically studying the Speed Force
although there isn't a name for it in
present-day science the cool thing about
this is it in the far future
eobard thawne professor zoom he was
basically studying the exact same thing
to Tracy brand is studying now because
in the future where Barr thought is from
there are no more flashes Barry Allen's
been dead for a long time the Speed
Force doesn't exist but they study it
like this mythical extra dimensional
energy field so that kind of gets into
Ivar thawne's origin story we don't need
to talk about that because it's not
necessarily connected to this but his
students call him professor zoom because
he's so smart about the flash he's a
professor of Flash studies in the Speed
Force which is kind of a funny
coincidence but number eight killer
frost
rolls in in her Louise Lincoln looking
costume so the pendant is very Louisa
Lincoln but it's kind of blended with
the new version of killer frost Caitlin
snows costume during rebirth and even
though they don't do a lot of the latest
comic-book stuff Caitlin snow is a good
character even though technically she's
a villain working on Batman's new
Justice League with Lobo so there is a
version of killer frost in the comics
right now that is bad but is doing good
things so it's a bit of a hat tip for
the future of Caitlin snows character
but this is really just a tee up for the
conflict that she has with Cisco and him
being afraid to kill his friend just
showing you that there's still a chance
that she could come back from darkness
and then number seven the secret coffee
menu this was so funny so tracy brand's
favorite coffee is on the secret menu is
a zoom so like they have the flash
coffee that was a big thing during
season two but now the secret coffee
menu is just a rogue's gallery of easter
eggs
for other flash villains so we have zoom
maybe in season force avatar will make
it onto the secret coffee menu who knows
how many shots of espresso will be in
that the zoom coffee just had like an
extra shot of espresso over the normal
flash coffee which already had crazy
caffeine in it compared to normal coffee
so it's just like as you go up the
speedster ladder it gets more and more
caffeinated so you just get crazier and
crazier
but number six this is so much fun the
flash versus Caitlin and she goes full
Iceman so if you haven't read the older
flash comics in a while this actually
looks a little bit like Louise Lincoln
powers from the comics not every version
of killer frost has been able to do this
use the ice trails to travel around
through midair but it's really badass
and I really want to go to that theme
park some days so maybe Warner Brothers
will build a flash roller coaster at
some point but he has mad skills and she
remembers their last fight so she gets
flash in the same spot where she got him
before so just a way of showing you that
she is a credible threat to the Blache
even though he's more powerful she can
still go toe-to-toe with them for at
least a little while if he has all his
wits about him which he does not right
now but number 5 welcome to team flash
Tracy so they have this really funny
moment where she gets all jazzed up
learning about her future
wait a minute you're telling me I'm like
Sarah Connor and terminator no no no
you're more like miles Dyson and it did
not end well for miles Dyson so I don't
think that implies that she's going to
die at the end of the season but it is
really cool to see that she can go toe
to toe with Cisco and pop-culture movie
references so it's just a subtle way of
showing you that she totally fits in on
this team she has this real insatiable
curiosity for the science of the flash
how do you run so fast and counteract
that static charge Cisco has fun talking
to her about the science of how the suit
works so it just gives her some of the
ideas that play in later to how she's
going to build the trap force avatar but
number 4 Barry has the really important
speech that sort of circles back around
at the end of the episode and helps him
realize who's Savitt are is is all about
love Joe if you don't have love then
what's worth fighting for it is the only
thing that matters in this world so he's
mostly talking about Iris about his
family shows mostly on the fence with
Cecile even though he loves her he's
just so afraid of what's going to happen
if he brings her into team flash so I'm
just really happy to see Barry for once
be the voice of reason that was what was
most important this I mean it was a
really nice speech it was very touching
but Barry is starting to take charge in
a way that he hasn't in the past usually
other characters like iris have to come
in and give him that speech instead now
he is slowly becoming a more mature
version of the character and he's the
one to give them the speech look this is
what it's all about you guys need to
chill he's super Zent about it number
three was Cisco versus Caitlin because
he got the bump from Julianne you know
the bump to get over his fear of hurting
Caitlin he tags in after Barry goes
down and it winds up being a twist on
the fight that you buy back during
episode 6 and the future Cisco told him
where he lost his hands so that was just
like the culmination of that original
fight but this time because of the
Julianne bump he has the courage to take
her down and even though they get a DNA
sample from her Savitt r runs in says
his ascension is nigh and then runs off
with her so for like the rest of the
episode they slowly start to put the
clues together and it starts it really
starts when Caitlin throws all of
Barry's words back at him as if she
knows exactly what he's going to say so
if you already weren't thinking it was
Barry I feel like this was the moment
where most people are like hey wait a
minute if she's saying the exact same
thing that Barry said and savat are told
her what Barry was going to say they add
that there's some crazy connection with
Barry it's probably buried but number
two back at STAR Labs Traci brand starts
to build her Savitt our track she's like
I have an idea you know I've been
studying speedsters Savitt our needs
that suit to counteract the static
charge so they can find a way to
counteract the effects of the suit they
can trap him so they're basically
building something to harness the power
of sabotage suit and use it against him
but number one as Joe comes back after
telling Cecile everything that is a
really positive moment where she's like
okay I'm totally in on team flash this
is going to be awesome so Joe and Cecile
are going to be mom and dad for the rest
of the series however long they survive
but as they're talking about love being
the most important thing Barry starts to
get the idea in his head wait a minute I
just have one thing I can figure out he
runs off any confronts avatar you know
everything about us you know how much we
love each other because you were there
when it happens and sure enough saboteur
walks out of the costume and it's like
the scarred version of Barry he has this
big scar over one of his eyes that's
mostly to differentiate between the two
versions so you know who regular Barry
is and you know who evil Barry is from
the future so I know you have a million
questions about how far in the future
he's from but the other really big
question and a lot of the reason why
people didn't think that it was very
early on because I'm like why would he
kill iris I don't understand
well what's probably happening is is
that this version of Barry like he has
that speech with killer frost where he
says we can be free of the pain and
suffering of this mortal existence I can
make your pain go away all you have to
do is kill Traci brand
so what's avatar is probably trying to
do is bring about
his creation through Berry's tragedy so
he wants to kill iris so that Barry will
go off the chain and eventually do
things that will lead him to become
saboteur so it's not exactly a bootstrap
paradox but it's sort of a
self-fulfilling prophecy
whereby he has this origin moment like
the moment he starts to become Salvatore
or starts on the path to becoming Sava
tar but the thing that we haven't got
yet that hopefully they'll do in the
next couple of episodes is where we get
the Wai explainer from future Barry why
did you do all this why is it so
important that you become Salvatore why
not fix things so that you can be in
love with Iris and be a happy family so
when it seems like it's happening is is
the future flash comic book storyline is
a Barry from 20-plus years in the future
who's got to this place in his life
where most of his friends are dead in
there are all kinds of fractures through
the Speed Force so it's almost like in
various pursuit of being a hero doing
good things saving people he's caused
all these problems and things have
gotten so bad that is a measure of last
resort he decides that he's going to go
back and kill himself so he won't be
able to cause all this damage in the
future so it's like I'm going to fix
everything by erasing myself from the
timeline so you can see that's not
what's happening here because Sava tar
has not been trying to kill Barry he's
been trying to get Barry to turn into
Sava tar
so this is a little bit like the Wally
West storyline where Mark Waid so this
is way back in the late 90s before the
Speed Force was created they just said
that the flash ran fast and that's it
there was no Speed Force before Mark
Waid came along then he came up with the
idea to explain the Flash's powers as a
function of this extra dimensional
energy source and wrote this story
called terminal velocity whereby Wally
West who was the main version of the
flash of the time Barry Allen was dead
he wasn't part of the flash comics Wally
West learns about the concept of the
Speed Force in that as he gets more and
more powerful and embraces his ability
he becomes more and more inhuman in to
achieve ultimate power he'll have to
leave all of his friends behind which he
does very briefly but then he comes back
so it's the idea that embracing your
full potential will mean leaving behind
all the things that you loved so that's
what's avatar is talking about when he
talks about his ascension achieving
ultimate power ultimate oneness with the
Speed Force so in order to do that
that he has to stop Barry from changing
the future in saving iris West if she
lives then he won't be able to become
saboteur but if you want to read that
story it's the flash terminal-velocity
its classic Mark Waid is a lot of fun it
actually happened before the savat our
arc in the comics so they're mixing and
matching a lot of things Savitt are in
the comics is a completely different
character so we'll talk about comic
books avatar in some of my future bonus
videos this week but let me know in the
comments what kind of videos do you want
me to do before next week's episode
anything you want me to clarify
specifically but what's going to happen
next is I'll post a trailer video for
the next episode and I'll address some
of the biggest comment the biggest
questions in this video in
congratulations to the latest flash ring
giveaway winner Micah Bowers please
private message me so I can get your
contact details there was a new round
that started in this video i'll announce
the winner when i post that trailer
video while you wait for that you can
click here for more sabotage and you can
click here for the latest defenders
teaser somebody special is coming back
from the dead thank you so much for
watching let's high-five I'll see you
guys tonight
you